jens stoltenberg peut-il éviter l'
escalade ces derniers mois est les
tensions n'ont cessé de grimper en
méditerranée orientale en cause les
explorations menées par la turquie dans
une zone maritime riche en hydrocarbures
dont la grèce réclame la souveraineté
cet été elle les deux pays ont multiplié
les démonstrations de force avec des
manoeuvres militaires faisant même
craindre le pire dans la région et pour
ne rien arranger le secrétaire général
de l'otan et jens stoltenberg semble
avoir des difficultés à jouer son rôle
de médiateur début septembre athènes
avait démenti des discussions avec
ankara à peine quelques heures après un
tweet du secrétaire général de l'otan
qui affirmait pourtant le contraire les
informations qui ont été révélés sur des
discussions techniques présumée à l'otan
ne correspondent pas à la réalité
nous avons retenu l'intention du
secrétaire général de l'otan de
travailler à la mise en place de
mécanismes de désescalade
cependant la désescalade n'aura lieu
qu'avec le retrait immédiat de tous les
navires turcs du plateau continental
grecque
jens stoltenberg aura-t-il plus de
succès cette fois ci alors que son
mandat arrive à sa fin certains
observateurs pointent du doigt une
tendance au double discours et la
pratique du deux poids deux mesures en
2016 jens stoltenberg avait affirmé que
l'alliance transatlantique ne
considérait pas la russie comme une
menace imminente
tout en se montrant très critique sur la
volonté de moscou de chercher à
constituer une zone d influence par des
moyens militaires
en revanche le secrétaire général de
l'otan n'a jamais eu de problème avec le
fait que les états unis utilisent leur
présence militaire en europe pour
rayonner au moyen-orient en asie et en
afrique
la présence américaine en europe n'a pas
seulement pour objectif de protéger
l'europe mais aussi de faire rayonner la
puissance des états unis en dehors de
celle ci on sait que de nombreuses
opérations américaines en irak
afghanistan et afrique sont lancés
depuis des bases
implanté en europe le commandement
militaire américain pour l'afrique n'est
pas en afrique mais à stuttgart en
allemagne
six ans après sa nomination au poste de
secrétaire général de l'otan pour de
nombreux
observateurs et n stoltenberg laissera
le souvenir d'un haut fonctionnaire qui
aura avant tout défendu les intérêts
américains dans la continuité de ses
prédécesseurs